Hey it's a beautiful day in May and
this tree right here is shedding these seeds everywhere
that look a lot like cotton balls
now it's not technically cotton
but its very light and fluffy the same way
and if you look on the ground here
you can see that they are pretty much everywhere
now you can see as you add the seeds together
it makes a nice big ball of fluff
it's very soft, very light and fluffy
see it's very easy to tear
this stuff should make some pretty good tinder
lets add it to our batch
now of course the first thing that comes to my mind is whether or not we could use these
to make some of that improvised char cloth i used cotton balls for in a previous project
so let's go fill up a tuna can with this stuff and put it on the burner and see if we can make some improvised fire starter
so I got quite a bit of this fluffy stuff, I also got a tuna can and you can see I poked a hole in the bottom there
if we shove all that down in there and put the lid back on top
makes a pretty tight seal
and now we can set that upright on a fire, a flame, a stove. whatever you want so long as there's quite a bit of heat
we want to cook this thing without letting oxygen get in
now when you go to cook char cloth that's as light and fluffy as this cotton type of stuff you want to make sure that no air can get in there
and this will pop open under pressure
so I'm just using, like, a rock, to sit on top there
and it's really important not to overcook this. We want to just heat it up until it makes the flame and when that flame goes down out of the top we want to stop
if we go any further than that our char cloth is not going to work
*blowtorch*
there it goes, we're done
now we just need to plug that hole with something, make sure that no air gets in there
something like that
and let it cool down
alright, it's actually only been about 2 minutes here but I'm just going to show you what would happen if we opened this up
here we go
oh
there you see this ones undercooked
this got really nicely charred but this other side is only half cooked but
let me take a piece off here, off the top and we're going to see if that'll work
as a proof of concept
now lets see how many of you remember what thing is
this is one of the earliest projects i did
it was my 14th preoject video
and I made it transparent so we can actually
see compression starting in action
and it worked with cotton balls, so I am curious
to see hows its going to work with this improvised char that
we made from this cotton seed
Now I need to do is just load the tip with
little bit of our char
You see that claw grabs everything in there pretty nicely
Once thats all on the set, we can go ahead and give
a nice big wack
Here we go
We did it right, we just got a little flash
and ofcourse once you get your tinder smoking
you can put in bundle, give it a little blow
It actually did light on fire. Thats cool!
Just wanna drop that down in there
That is getting pretty close to gone up in flames
I had to bring this outside, so I didn't set up
this smoke detector in the house
So I wrapped another piece of paper towel around it
just to give it a little more fuel
but I wanna light this thing up for ya and
it should only take a few breaths of fresh air
And when you are trying to get your tinder to light
its best just to let it to smoulder in its own pace
you dont wanna rush it
you go too fast
Its not gonna like that
You can see this smoke is starting to get really thick
Oh! Here we go
FIRE!
Whoa! That wasn't as easy as I thought it was gonna be
but atleast we got it to work